[Musik]
matthias schmidt trainiert für einen
triathlon und ist darum stets um seinen
kalorien haushalte besorgt er ist karte
man bei der swisscom und so gut wie
immer erreichbar
notfalls schon vor dem frühstück schon
aufgelaufen und mal geschaut was ist
irgendwie jetzt finde ich wichtig aber
es ist noch nichts beziehungsweise eine
e-mail ist wichtig gewesen da musste ich
jetzt gerade mal antworten und das
weitere gleich im büro
[Musik]
stefan grötzinger ist
energiebeauftragter der stadt will ihm
wird es manchmal zu viel mit der
ständigen digitalen verfügbarkeit annina
mutter hat rund 15.000 follower das sind
15.000 menschen die sich für alles
interessieren was sie macht
oder ist wann hast du versucht kontrakts
weg und treffen ließ wichtig findet dass
man sich darauf konzentriert was man
isst
ich weiß nicht wie das bei anderen ist
aber es ist mein job überall in dem teil
innerhalb hallo
sorry ich hab ich habe auch schon mega
viel teurer und halt einfach an ist doch
riesig mit innovationen
das ist gut
du bist nicht im hub oder schmid
arbeitet oft im sogenannten pirates of
the swiss com
hier hat keiner mehr einen fixen
arbeitsplatz wichtig ist nur dass man
sich einloggt und das geht ja überall
auch zu hause an ihrer mutter ist
schauspielerin und model vor allem aber
auch bloggerin und internet
persönlichkeit ein beruf mit zukunft
sagt sie aber jetzt zum beispiel
möglichkeit zum foto schoss um 317 zum
mitmachen völlig unabhängig vor allem
andere selbständig zu schaffen und das
finde ich schon unglaublichen mühen und
wenn ich im büro sitze vorn 1 2 von der
länge das ist tot
grözinger ist verantwortlich für den
zukunftstag mobilität und energie der
stadt wil ziel für smarte lösungen
sensibilisieren
neben shows in die virtuelle realität
und smart city in der virtuellen
realität können schon kinder das auto
ihrer eltern so optimieren dass es
weniger treibstoff verbraucht
hier geht es richtung zukunft mit
vollgas und digital
wir müssen reichen aber nicht aus sie
muss landkreise man sie irgendwie nichts
gibt
denn die schöne ziel
[Musik]
schmidt weiß dass es nur die wenigsten
genießen können keinen empfang zu haben
[Musik]
darum arbeitet die swisscom daran dass
wir künftig überall netz haben auch auf
den höchsten bergen und in den tiefsten
täler und wie weit sollte man damit dann
irgendwie gehen schmid der daran
mitarbeiter sind sich indes nach mehr
momenten in denen er offline sein darf
was ist dein schönster vermieter reich
barisch ich glaube so der für mich
wirklich auch die zeit mahlzeit sein
lassen und sich nicht wirklich von einer
minute auf die nächste zu hetzen und
sich mit sich beschäftigen
die digitalisierung ist für schmied und
viele andere ein stressfaktor was vor 30
jahren richtig anfliegen hat
offensichtlich auch schattenseiten im
herbst 91 fällt der startschuss für ein
europäisches mobiltelefon system in der
schweiz natel de genannt
hauptakteur im europäischen
mobiltelefonmarkt bis der schwedische
konzern eriksson mit 70.000
beschäftigten und 10 milliarden
schweizer franken umsatz einer der
international großen in der branche
taschen telefone sind das hauptprodukt
der betrieb kupfer produziert sie für
verschiedene mobiltelefon systeme in
aller welt
nach einer zeit von 56 jahren könnten
sich vorstellen einen geräten diesem
größe ungefähr ein drittel von was wir
heute haben
damals war unsere gegenwart noch
science-fiction
aber man konnte sich vorstellen dass
sich grundsätzliches ändern würde und
versuchte die bevölkerung darauf
vorzubereiten
das ziel heißt personal communication
was ist damit gemeint
wer heute telefoniert ruft nicht
personen an sondern fest installierte
telefone zb im büro in der wohnung oder
im ferienhaus
und das ist personal communication jeder
mann jede frau hat eine ganz persönliche
telefonnummer zur personal communication
gehört ferner ein persönliches taschen
telefon dass alle auf sich tragen dieses
telefon ersetzt die bisherigen
telefonapparate für mich persönlich
bedeutet es totale freiheit ich bin
nicht mehr hier am tisch gebunden ich
kann mir und in den ganzen büro bewegen
ich kann auf die straße gehen oder ich
kann sogar nach hause gehen und noch
mehr zur verfügung zu stellen für andere
leute dazu kommt dass die gerät hat eine
knopf und das heißt ich kann das ja auch
ausschalten
das gehört auch zur freiheit von mtw
arrangierten szenen in einem zürcher
restaurant eines lokal voll telefonieren
damit menschen heute fiktion morgen
könnten solche bilder zum alltag gehören
am mittagstisch die gestresste
fortsetzung der morgen geschäfte für das
persönliche gespräch unter kollegen
bleibt kaum zeit
der traum von der totalen kommunikation
pervertiert zum alptraum
fazit wir müssen lernen die totale
kommunikation zu beherrschen andernfalls
wird sie in zukunft uns beherrschen
[Musik]
beim ausatmen stell dir vor wie die
sonnenstrahlen sich in einem ganzen
körper anfangen zu verteilen
mit jeder einatmung wächst die sonne und
jede ausatmen verteilen sich die
sonnenstrahlen in einem ganzen körper
sie alle haben ihre handys abgegeben um
endlich mal weg vom netz und nachher bei
sich zu sein dann verbinde dich mit
deinem nachbarn einen fokuspunkt in die
weite zurück zur mitte atmet tief ein
dann bleibt stark in der mitte während
die diffus hinten nix für mich geht es
immer da oben körper geist und seele
eigentlich hier in einen gewissen
einklang zu stellen und gesundheit
grundsätzlich mit den mit in den alltag
zu nehmen und auch seine ruhezonen sich
dort irgendwo zu finden und nicht das
kurzfristige immer zu optimieren sondern
eigentlich das gesamte zu sehen und auch
eine gewisse langfrist eigentlich mit
den die perspektive einfließen zu lassen
eine hütte oberhalb von kandersteg ist
für die nächsten tage zu hause
der berner oberländer tourismus hat die
gestressten städter als zielgruppe
entdeckt und offeriert neuerdings ein
sogenanntes digital die talks camp
digital die talks das ist ein
modebegriff und bedeutet digitales
entgiften in dem konsequent auf alle
elektronischen empfangsgeräte verzichtet
wird
man legt das handy weg und beschäftigt
sich unter professioneller anleitung mit
sich und seiner umwelt
sie sind also das ist ein absolut nicht
vermissen
als ich sie zu dem moment wo man
zwischen torlose klarstellung von philip
missler aber die ist jetzt nicht gefragt
ist sehr schön und ich bin zutiefst ich
spreche sie und gar nicht im moment
kommen und ist wild cards medizin trug
vor
[Applaus]
alle teilnehmer waren vor einem jahr
schon mal hier jetzt treffen sie sich zu
einer reunion und zu einer erneuten
auszeit vom digitalen alltag
keiner von ihnen möchte die
digitalisierung müssen aber manchmal was
sie ihnen alles über den kopf
er sei oft schwierig sich abzugrenzen
das handy dauerhaft abzugeben ist aber
keine option als orthodoxe offliner
während sie gar nicht vermittelbar in
ihren berufsfeldern als ich mir einen
tee trinken
der berliner verband wie wir ihn auch
nicht wirklich wahrscheinlich das album
sweet machen
in dieser übung geht es um achtsamkeit
schmitt und co sollen versuchen die welt
mit allen sinnen bewusster wahrzunehmen
das können sie später in den alltag
einbauen und so stress abbauen
wie viele dieser red
wie fühlen sie sich sehr gut
schon interessant aus der
geräuschkulisse etwas mitzunehmen die
füße sind ganz kalt die nasenspitze wird
gewärmt von der sonne und die
verschiedenen untergründe wie kann man
schon auf sich wirken lassen weil sind
es also schon schmerzhaft bei spitzen
steinen jetzt im wasserwerk kann es sind
viele runde steine auch dort dabei die
sich dem fußboden ganz gut anschlägen
also sind sehr viele sinne und
impressionen die sollen angesprochen
werden von mir
[Musik]
annina mutter ist eine art online
werbeträgerin firmenzahlen ihr geld
damit sie ihren followern gewisse
produkte präsentiert in diesem fall
nachhaltig und fair produzierte kleidung
aufzeigen
das verlangen öko und irgendwie vollkorn
muss und dass es durchaus erfreuliche
sache gibt und das gehört tempo
eine befreundete fotografin knipst und
mutter verdient daran die bilder später
online zu stellen und mit einer subtilen
werbebotschaft zu versehen
[Musik]
der user will was sehen für seinen krieg
und mutter liefert mit ganzkörpereinsatz
aber auch sie wird nicht jünger
für den flick flack auf beton ja dafür
wenn sie haben mit touristischen
forscherin aroma und wie instagram video
metrix gedroht dass gut die frag ich
glaube ich bin jetzt gerade bei
instagram esther seitlich offen von ali
und die jüngeren sind auf anderen
plattformen wie snapshot und musical und
wie die alle heißen und soll ich mich
jetzt bei instagram metris kind ohne
gewinnes oma ja du hast wahrscheinlich
in meinen daten nach herum studiert oder
eine smart watch laut schmitz triathlon
trainingsdaten laufen die neue cloud
hoch sein coach in münchen analysiert
und interveniert quasi in echtzeit dass
persönliche daten mehr als chance zur
selbstoptimierung wobei auch schmidt
weiß keine chancen ohne risiken
man spricht ja auch irgendwie von in
diesem brief im moment wenn man
irgendwie in facebook mit seinen
kollegen chattet über den friseurtermin
und eben im selben maße dann eine
werbung hier ist der nächste friseur
eingeblendet wird
dann fühlt man sich so vielleicht sind
es zufälle vielleicht sind wir auch
keine zufälle und das sind für mich
momente wo ich sagen moment mal da
stimmt doch irgendwie was nicht alice
doch irgendwie jemand mit und versucht
mich vielleicht auch aktiv zu
beeinflussen und somit also mich störte
das ob es angst macht es mir nicht aber
ich glaub mich stört ist insofern als
dass ich da einen gewissen gewisse
direkte beeinflussung viele die ich
nicht akzeptiere und auch nicht möchte
sie ernährt sich vegan
das ist kein geheimnis aber ihre
follower wissen noch mehr über sie noch
viel mehr zum beispiel wo sie ist was
sie ist und mit wem sie ist sie lässt
die algorithmen auch so sehr weit in ihr
leben
wo ist die grenze an der schlafzimmertür
ließe sie sich auch durch eine maschine
verkuppeln ich bin offen in person so
viele menschen so dass auch krozinger
brauchte keine digitale hilfe auf der
suche nach der liebe
aber jetzt da er sie gefunden hat kommt
ihm sein handy ab und dann sieg wäre
[Gelächter]
ich möchte einen film machen usain bolt
ich glaube das passt am besten zu mir
dass wir werden welche technologien dein
leben in zukunft verändern
dieser roboter heißt pepper erhält im
haus auf swisscom in basel warten die
kunden bei laune und stimmt sie
kauffreudig vielleicht kommt bald noch
mehr sind ich was er für mich erledigen
könnte kochen also ja gibts ja schon
wieder irgendwie so salat schneiden das
mache ich aber dann vielleicht lieber
selber haben wir vereinzelt ich glaube
nicht also so viele berichte über
probleme reden habe ich also da habe ich
bisher noch meine meine freunde mit
denen ich mich dann lieber im café auf
einen kaffee treffen und mit denen das
wirklich jeder stadt jetzt ihm von
meinen sorgen und nöten zu erzählen und
er dann ja auch wenn er da liebt daher
schaut bin ich mir nicht so sicher ob er
das wirklich alles versteht
in japan ist das längst realität
roboter ersetzen fielen die
zwischenmenschliche kontakte etwa bei
senioren
[Musik]
es ist die zeit gekommen um einmal
einfach zu sein
dann streckt ein mal die zunge heraus
und lass alles locker hin und vom tun
gehen wir über zu sein es gibt nichts zu
tun und wir sind glücklich darüber sein
zu dürfen
offline zu bleiben ist keine option
ziel ist hier viel mehr eine art
digitale selbsterkenntnis zu verstehen
was wir mit der digitalisierung machen
und was sie mit uns macht und sich
konsequenter abzugrenzen
ich glaube merkt doch liegt der flachs
man hätte mir signale schmutz am tisch
saßen und einigen apps wie google oder
das datum im kalender eintragen oder
regen wir ich glaube ja so die einzelnen
romand aber weg vermisster finde das
schön stimmt das lässt sich für die das
sagt mir dass ich mache und dann hat der
hektische alltag sieht plötzlich wieder
alles kann sich gar nicht ändern aber
auch nicht nichts
sie muss erreichbar bleiben aber nicht
immer und auch nicht überall
ich glaube ich hatte schoss bewusst sie
für moment was wirklich wichtig ist
apple auch mal lax lecker und versuche
das große bundesliga will wenn man
schulden mir im alltag ist und so weiter
und dann die weniger moment wo man
zusammenhält was man darf wirklich bin
richtig genießen
das versuchen auch grözinger und seine
freundin die wenigen gemeinsamen momente
zu genießen
auch wenn es bisweilen fast eine
dreiecksbeziehung ist ihr sie und das
handy deswegen verstehe ist auch dass er
es bedürfnis hat online zu sein und up
to date zu sein aber es wird ihm
wahrscheinlich schon einmal gut tun
am zu schießen schmied will für eine
freundin kochen und youtube soll helfen
die beiden kennen sich wie könnte es
anders sein aus dem internet
und zwar
wenn ihr aus deutschland china online
zusammengeführt in zürich wenn das
grundsatzentscheidung wäre entweder
haben sie internetzugang oder jank
geruchssinn wie würde sie sich zu
entscheiden
schwer zu sagen wahrscheinlich ist das
jetzt sehr rational betrachtet dann für
den internetzugang weil über den kann
ich mir im zweifel auch was zu essen
bestellen
fast die hälfte der schweizer
beantwortet diese frage genau so wie
schmidt lieber online bleiben aus weiter
riechen können
gleichzeitig wünschen sich immer mehr
menschen oasen ohne anschluss in dem
fall ist mein telefon schon im flugmodus
das heißt wenn ich zu hause bin und
gäste habe dann gibt's bei mir einfach
kein empfang im moment of line and bin
ich allein
egal wie diese reise weitergeht mensch
sein und leben das wird wohl nie nur
digital gehen sondern immer auch analog